(Forrest, voice-over]
I have been flying to
San Francisco monthly
to pick up my son Eric
for our weekends together.
It seemed natural
that I would invite
my new lady-friend Shampoo
to join me on my next trip
and voila: membership
in the Mile High Club.
I'm really excited
to meet your son.
Yeah.
- I really like kids.
- Mmm.
Hey, look...
now that we are...
one mile up in the air,
do you want to, uh...
[clicks tongue]
- [laughs]
- What?
[whispers] Let's go have sex
in the bathroom.
[whispers] I'm not gonna
have sex in the bathroom.
- Why not?
- It's gross.
- What's gross about it?
- People are [bleep] in there.
Oh, come on.
This is a short flight,
I don't think anybody is
pooping on the way
up to San Francisco.
- Come on.
- Is that why you invited me?
- No.
- Because I'm a stripper...
So I'd be up for that?
Right?
- No.
- Gross.
Everybody on this plane
likes to have sex.
(Shampoo)
You know what?
If it was all about sex for me,
I would have found somebody
a lot hotter!
That is one of
the rudest things
that anyone
has ever said to me.
[scoffs]
[crying]
I thought you were different.
I thought maybe for once
I met a nice guy.
I'm gonna give you
some space.
(Forrest, voice-over)
Rather than turned
on by the idea of sex
in an airplane bathroom,
Shampoo--
a professional clothes remover,
seemed stunned.
My trip to the Mile High Club
with her was,
as they say in the travel
business, cancelled.
I would need to find someone
on this flight
more sexually adventurous
than a stripper.
And just when
all seemed lost...
Uh, excuse me. Sorry.
Sorry to bother you.
Can I switch seats with you
by any chance?
(man) What?
- I'm in 23D.
Just right up there.
Thank you very--ah, thank you.
- Yeah, that's great.
- Ass[bleep].
Thank you so much.
It is middle seat.
(Forrest, voice-over)
After pouring out every ounce
of available charm
on to this woman Beth,
I was clearly,
incredibly enough,
being considered
for admission into the club.
- Yes, exactly.
- [laughs]
You can go into space
without being an astronaut.
(Captain)
We have begun
our initial descent
into San Francisco
International Airport.
Please return to your seats
and make sure
your seatbelts
are securely fastened.
Hey, Beth...
This is gonna sound crazy.
[whispers] I wanna have
sex with you right now.
[laughs]
- Right now?
- Yeah, right now.
Let's just follow
this moment.
Did you feel it?
- Yeah, I did.
- I knew it.
Okay, so, will you
sneak to the bathroom
with me right now
and have sex?
- So, we gonna [bleep]?
- Yeah.
[pings]
It's just
the seatbelt light's on.
- Yeah, so?
- When we get to the airport
take a cab
to the closest hotel.
Listen, I can't wait
that long.
Okay, we'll find a place
in the airport.
No, I can't wait
that long, either.
- No, seriously...
- No, it's super dangerous.
No, it's not
that dangerous.
(Forrest, voice-over)
Beth could obviously disregard
many of societies
guidelines for how to behave,
but not, for some reason,
the seatbelt sign.
I don't wanna do it
in an airport bathroom.
I wanna do it
in an airplane bathroom.
- Seriously.
- Yeah, but the seatbelt sign
- is on--
- Who cares about the sign?
- Seriously?
- Let's go to a nice hotel.
No, thank you.
Oh, my God.
Oh, hey, what about
another flight?
No, don't touch me!
Okay?